you remember the tailors old as 1991 now
experience it all over again with CGI
and celebrities as Disney reminds us
it's not about how you look it's what's
on the inside of your wallet that counts
Beauty and the Beast again after the
Jungle Book used live action to improve
on their animated classic Disney's using
live-action to just copy their animated
classic and see if anyone notices or
cares turns out they don't in an empty
spectacle that reminds you how good the
original was and shows you how creepy
the original would be if it were real
mom said I wasn't supposed to me return
to the British Astarte friends come
remember Walter crazy all blurry
little sprint to East Wing and meet
Belle a beautiful book lover who falls
in love with an ugly dude so Hermione
Emma Watson turned down an oscar-winning
role in la-la-land for this but she
deserves an Oscar for not laughing every
time danced even showed up in his mocap
suit watch her inhabit this strong
female role model who isn't afraid to
invent her own washing machine laundry
and doesn't need a man to help her
express herself unless that man's name
is auto-tune
remember
auto-tuned you get it but it's not all a
rehash of the original there are several
new tiny crumbs of movie to pick over
like superfluous backstory wandering
around the woods diversity and the play
kids love the play
plus a new Oscar baiting song that will
have you wondering if you have enough
time to take a deep breath no she'll
know you do Gaston shines as the
aggressive controlling hairy guy who
imprisons Belle's dad as opposed to the
beast an aggressive controlling hairy
guy who imprisons Belle's dad and if
you're mad we reuse the same joke we
made in our original honest trailer then
you're not one of the millions of Disney
fans who defend this glorified rehash
blink and you'll miss the reveal of
Disney's first openly gay character
assuming you don't count Prince Erik
asla Fuu finally comes out of the closet
to piss off everyone because gay people
don't want their first character to be a
sniffling evil weirdo while homophobes
want the scene to be more gay so they
could get really hot and bothered
seriously that's it that's the moment
that got it banned in Kuwait Malaysia
and Alabama I've seen gayer stuff for
breakfast so be Disney's guest at this
timeless tale of how it's your inner
beauty that matters the beauty is found
within even though Belle is hot the
beast is hot the dresser is hot
the librarian is hot and even the wizard
oak crone turns out to be hard because
while inner beauty is what really
matters your ugly ass has definitely
occurs starring miss wooly in josh glad
Fabio
Emma Stone's favorite Belle obi-wan he
in the clock ed and Belle's mom kissed
by a rose on the grave
reboot II and the Beast yay the royal
prince is back but wait if Gaston had a
musket then this takes place either
right before or right after the French
Revolution uh-oh
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb my voice makes Morgan Freeman pee
his pants
some King llama from my iPad I pooped on
the floor like a naughty little
chihuahua people of the world
lend me your energy